okay so do you ever want something so
badly or think to yourself for so long
something would be so cool but then you
accept in yourself that it's just never
ever going to happen and in one day you
find out it's been announced that that
thing is happening if you don't know
about it I will tell you about it now at
Comic Con this is the biggest news of
Comic Con so far that I've seen yeah
there's been some Justice League stuff
and guardians of the galaxy but this is
the game changer to me and I'm gonna
give you a spoiler alert I'm talking
about Man of Steel too so if you haven't
seen Man of Steel there are some
spoilers in here you've been warned now
you know it was announced that in the
next Man of Steel movie the Man of Steel
sequel Batman is going to be in and it
was announced some years ago that a
Batman Superman crossover was gonna
happen it just never happened now it's
it's actually happy to Zack Snyder was
like this is happening and it's not some
unlinked unrelated will Batman Superman
crossover movie but it's unrelated to
Man of Steel no this is the Man of Steel
sequel directed by Zack Snyder written
by David s Goyer has henry cavill the
whole cast is returning it's the Man of
Steel sequel and in that sequel Batman
the best part is is how they announced
it you could have announced this with a
tweet and it'd just be nuts but now Zack
Snyder had harry lennix come out harry
lennix is the guy who played the general
and Man of Steel and harry lennix reads
a quote and the quote was I want you to
remember Clark in all the years to come
in your most private moments I want you
to remember my hand at your throat I
want you to remember the one man who
beat you and then the Superman s symbol
that's not an S it's a symbol of hope
came up on screen with the bat symbol
behind it and I guess fans in the room
just freaked the [ __ ] out I wasn't there
but a pretty sure it was pretty cool
just as sure as I am that any man in
that room later on in life will hold his
firstborn son for the first time with
his wife who was just in labor for about
48 hours next woman he will say to her
this is the second most magical moment I
have ever been a part of yeah seriously
this is crazy news and people were like
all's gonna be Christian Bale at Joseph
gordon-levitt I don't that I think the
Dark Knight trilogy is its own thing
this will not have that Batman this will
be a new Batman you see the bat symbol
that's behind the Superman symbol and
it's ultimately from the Dark Knight
Returns point is it's not a Nolan Batman
symbol from The Dark Knight movie so I
don't think it's going to be a Nolan
type Batman this is Batman not from The
Dark Knight movie and of course the
implication that the Dark Knight Returns
is inspiration for this new movie you
think
William Batman in the Dark Knight Rises
went away and now he can return but he's
already returned he returned in the Dark
Knight Rises that was the point of that
movie that'll be redundant and I don't
think they were illustrating that the
Dark Knight Returns his inspiration for
this new movie because of Batman in his
whole story arc I think they're trying
to illustrate the relationship that
Batman and Superman are gonna have which
is they're not gonna be pals I imagine
by the end of the movie they'll work
together for the common good but they're
just they're not really friends when
they meet they're not really friends a
lot of the time and then the thought
comes to mind well then he won't have
any build up and we won't know him you
know Batman by now you know him you know
Batman's story but if Batman is some
sort of antihero in this story if he is
going up against Superman and I'm not
saying he's a villain but he is
basically the role of what a villain
would play in a movie with Superman in
which case if you're stable Batman
doesn't have any build up to this and we
don't know him you know him as much as
you would know any other villain that
would go up head-to-head against
Superman I'm just saying any character
in a role like that doesn't need his own
movie to build it up especially if it's
Batman who you know by now just like
Superman you know Superman by now I say
that to people who are like it's too
soon for Superman to have a crossover no
it's not if DC is seriously going to
contend with the Marvel Universe that is
expanding and doing crossovers all the
time now they are going to have to do a
crossover now or at least in 2015 which
is when this Man of Steel sequel is
coming out and it makes sense to have
your two flagship characters meeting up
in one movie so I think to myself how
will they incorporate Bruce Wayne into
this world and I don't know for sure
these are just all my theories My Mind's
been racing a hundred miles an hour
since I've heard this news I'm thinking
to myself okay you have Metropolis and
half of that city got wiped down
I always thought Lex Luthor would come
in because he's like hey I'll help
rebuild the city because I'm a good guy
like that right yeah but now I'm
thinking to myself what if two
billionaires from the DC Universe got
together and they rebuilt metropolis
they have Lex Luthor and Bruce Wayne
working together to rebuild metropolis
Lex Luthor is a pretty slick guy you
know so what if Lex Luthor and Bruce
Wayne start out as friends then Superman
finds out that Lex Luthor is actually a
dick and he's going up against him and
then Bruce Wayne's like all right he
suits up in Batman suit and he's like
why are you going after that nice man
dude we're trying to rebuild metropolis
why are you being such a child and then
they clash and I think it would be
really interesting if Bruce Wayne starts
out on the side of Lex Luthor really has
no reason to hate him at that point so
why not they're all being good guys but
ultimately Bruce Wayne Batman
he's a cautious guy you have this kal-el
who is the same species as the Zod that
wasted metropolis his Bruce Wayne gonna
trust him know he's got trust issues
he's not going to and this is a stretch
but it would still be kind of cool if
Batman's like you killed Zod I don't
kill I do that voice and not the hockey
pads voice because it's like I says I'm
gonna be Christian Bale I don't think
and from there your mind races to a
hundred directions as to how they could
take that kind of conflict and I don't
know for sure like I said my mind is
just racing and I'm coming up with [ __ ]
that's just like maybe maybe it's how my
mind works the point is I cannot wait to
see this movie I always love it when
Superman and Batman they're clashing I'm
pretty sure Batman's not going to win in
this movie because it's Superman's movie
but that would be great if Batman
humbles him a little bit indestructible
you beat Zod doesn't matter the Avengers
to Star Wars Episode seven and Man of
Steel sequel with Batman aka Batman
Superman crossover all in 2015 that is
the year to know right there I feel like
another economic crisis is going to
happen because you can't have that much
awesome without some bad to
counterbalance it otherwise it's just
called heaven it is called heaven on
earth and we will all be there to
experience it so discussed below Batman
in the new Man of Steel sequel what do
you think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know oh and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you